[Music]
i still lose sleep over
this fact
okay i still lose sleep over it and i
want you to lose sleep too i don't want
to be the only one staring at the
ceiling at night i'm going to tell you
uh
a lot of things already beat you to that
sure i mean the asteroid strike that
could happen or the exactly right or the
global warming or
so here it is you may remember or you
may have heard that einstein's
relativity right more more specifically
you learn this in special theory of
relativity where
the faster you move
right
the
slower time ticks for you right
as others view it relative to the
observer relative to the observer
correct you don't know anything's
happening right
your clock still ticks as far you still
got your your heart beat all of this
okay so this is not a physiological
thing is an actual property
of the fabric of space and time under
those conditions wow
okay that is fascinating it is it's
completely fascinating it's completely
so
i watch you fly by and the faster you go
the slower time ticks for you okay but
my time stays the same to you to me to
you so not only does speed do this also
the strength of a gravitational field
will have the same effect on you the
stronger the gravitational field is the
slower time ticks for you and that
wasn't formulated until his general
theory of relativity um uh ten years
later that took a lot more math and
and and deeper insights
into the universe but once again it
makes sense because you're dealing with
the fabric of space time it's the fabric
of space time correct but initially when
formulated you're thinking it's just
because you're moving right but it's
it's actually way deeper than that and
that's why that one oh by the way his
original special theory of relativity
was not called that
the title of the research paper was on
the electrodynamics of moving bodies
what okay that was that was the title we
would later call it the special theory
of relativity because it was a special
case of what would later then be called
the general theory of relativity oh oh
while we're there let me just slip this
in the gps satellites
orbit higher than our
um than our
then like the space station and right
and other things that are what we call
low earth
they're in like mio the middle earth
orbit there's leo mio and geo okay
if you have kids maybe you name him that
yes
leo meal and geo
lowest ortho middle earth orbit and uh
geosynchronous geo
geo orbit okay so the the geosynchronous
satellites are are like middle orbit
that is far enough away from earth's
source of gravity
for them to have a difference a
measurably different space-time
condition
so that their clocks tick faster than
our clocks on earth's surface
because they're farther away
and so remember i said the the more
intense the gravitational gravitation
slower the slower time ticket so they're
farther away their time ticks faster
relative to us
wow but we get precise timings from
geosynchronous satellites
so how does this work
we pre-correct
the time signal from the gps satellites
to compensate for einstein's general
theory of relativity so that by the time
the time reaches us where it's been
properly corrected and it matters to us
and our space-time continuum not the one
that's in middle-earth orbit oh my
goodness
so gps couldn't work as accurately as it
does however wait a minute what i'm
sorry just for me
you would have to have
a standard
in order to pre-correct something
you know the rate at which its time is
speeding up because you can calculate
what the gravitational field is up there
there you go there you go okay okay and
once you calculate that then you do and
you say oh my gosh we the the the
formula works einstein was right
right right this is not just something
on a few high theory but hypothesize
that may or may not be true it is true i
just want to be there when that phrase
is uttered oh my god
einstein was right
yeah these aren't just cult heroes that
we wish they were right right these are
real this is real okay this is the real
universe we're talking about here okay
so now watch
let's keep going faster and faster let's
go half the speed of light three
quarters of speed 90 the speed of light
99 the speed of light time is ticking
slower and slower and slower
for you you will watch the whole future
history of the universe
unfold in front of your eyes
as fractions of a second go by for you
as you go 99 there's a formula for this
of course but 99 99.9 99.99
the speed of light because you're the
observer of that but for you
your time has slowed to the point
where as you observe
the things that are not
moving at the speed of light
you see them
speeding correctly you see them unfold
correct boom correct that is insane so
now watch oh my god wait no watch okay
wow so
i didn't even get to the part where i
lose sleep okay
okay that's what happens by the way by
the way um
there are particles that decay you've
heard of like radioactivity right yes
yes one part it decays and becomes
another point it releases the often
deadly energy yes okay radioactivity all
right some particles let's take for
example the
uh proton
uh or the
the muon
one of these uh decays in like six
minutes when it's left out in the in the
wild okay when it's not part of an atom
okay when it's not in captivity i forgot
which of these it doesn't matter for my
example decay isn't like six minutes
okay
okay
what happens if you take that particle
and speed it up in a particle
accelerator
so you take a a a community of these
particles speed them up
calculate wait a minute the internal
wrist watch on these clocks says they
should live longer and sure enough
their decay time takes longer wow
that's oh my god yes yes oh wow yes and
that becomes that becomes living proof
of what einstein said yes because we
can't go half the speed of light right
you can accelerate a particle to do that
yeah it's an internal built-in clock
that decays after a certain amount of
time and there they are taking longer to
decay in the exact amount that einstein
predicts that's genius so we don't make
this stuff up okay it yes it is genius
it's like triple genius all right
now let's take this to an extreme
level
right let's go so fast
that we're going the speed of light
itself
right well we can't do that because
we're made of material substance and
that's there's no way to do that but
there are things that travel at the
speed of light and what is that
uh
those would be photons yes
that would be
i would say
what travels at the speed of light light
does yeah okay i was about to say light
so if photons
had a clock
the clock would never tick
nice
which means when i go to a mountaintop
as i did in graduate school
to observe the center of the milky way
galaxy
for stars
that emitted their light 30 000 years
ago traveling through the gaps of
interstellar space and they moved
through space come through earth's
atmosphere they come down into the
telescope they reflect go back to my
detector and land on my ccd chip
that photon when it was born
at the star that emitted it
was detected at my telescope
in the same instant
wow
according to the photon itself
live fast die hard
photon has no
knowledge of that trip
right because time did not exist for it
oh that's great and i'm saddened that's
many of these photons like hit people's
tanning on the beach you know and and to
how they're imagining 30 000 years and
land on someone's buttocks
with the telescope i collected i'm now
decoding the nature of the universe not
and some photons go right on by earth
and are still moving but they have no
internal time clock
wow
and they're just traveling through like
i hope when i'm born i hit a telescope
bam you're you're born a telescope
yeah yeah that would be an interesting
but when i what i want to be when i grow
up or you know or the instant i am
admitted where am i going to be where i
like to be right right right and so just
the idea that light can move across the
universe and have no
uh and not age this is a fascinating
fact to me
wow so yeah that is that is more than
fascinating yeah yeah i mean that's
mind-boggling yeah yeah so that is light
the age of light it's like it doesn't
age at all i am convinced that all of
you guys secretly micro dose and smoke
weed
i'm just that's another
all right chuck we're calling it quits
there all right all right mysteries of
light and time uh neil degrasse tyson
here keep looking out
[Music]
you